vamos a tratar de resolver el siguiente
ejercicio y dice el número de mosquitos
en millones y lo están
denotando con la letra m entonces la
letra m dice el número de millones de
mosquitos que hay en brooklyn nueva york
depende de los centímetros de lluvia en
junio y los centímetros de lluvia en
junio los están denotando con la letra r
dice y puede modelar se con la función m
igual a menos r por r menos 4 muy bien
entonces el número de mosquitos depende
del de los centímetros de lluvia y está
dependiendo de esta forma verdad - r por
r menos 4 dice bueno por supuesto hay
que resolver algunas preguntas y yo te
invito a a ver si puedes inspirarte y
ver si puedes resolver estas preguntas
por tu cuenta muy bien como siempre si
no vamos a hacerlo nosotros juntos la
primera dice a partir de cuántos
centímetros de lluvia habrá una
población de 0 millones de mosquitos
bien quizás parece
para la pregunta pero bueno es una
pregunta válida digamos a mí me sirve
reescribir la función tenemos igual a
menos r que multiplica a r - 4 muy bien
entonces la pregunta es cuándo o para
qué valores de r vamos a tener que m es
igual a cero porque entonces vamos a
tener cero creo que debería dejar el
otro color tendremos cero igual a menos
r
por r menos 4 muy bien entonces la
pregunta es que para qué valores de r
esta ecuación tiene sentido y realmente
lo que tenemos que analizar es lo
siguiente tenemos un producto de dos
números podríamos pensar en este número
que es menos cr y podríamos pensar en
este otro número que es de menos 4 que
dejen déjenme hacerlo con otro color que
es r menos cuatro muy bien entonces si
tenemos un producto de dos números que
nos da cero eso quiere decir que alguno
de ellos
tenía que ser cero verdad entonces
quiere decir que menos r era cero o bien
quiere decir que r - 40 muy bien vamos a
ver qué pasa en el primer caso pues si
menos r es igual a cero podemos
multiplicar por menos uno de ambos lados
y vamos a obtener que r es igual a cero
o bien si tenemos el otro caso podemos
sumar cuatro de ambos lados y tendremos
que r es igual a cuatro muy bien
entonces podemos pensar en la
interpretación de este problema si es
que está muy bien modelado verdad si no
tenemos lluvia quiere decir que hay cero
mosquitos verdad 60 centímetros de
lluvia quiere decir que hay 0 millones
de mosquitos y eso tiene sentido a lo
mejor no hay dónde puede desarrollarse
la población no pueden no se alimentarse
de algo que se desarrolle en la lluvia o
qué sé yo muy bien sin embargo nos dice
que cuando tenemos 4 centímetros de
lluvia pues no sé a lo mejor es
demasiada lluvia a lo mejor se ahoga
a lo mejor su vida se vuelve difícil
cuando hay tanta lluvia de agua a lo
mejor la lluvia arrastra los mosquitos y
se los llevan no no lo sé realmente el
punto es que con mucha lluvia los
mosquitos no pueden sobrevivir y
entonces hay cero millones de mosquitos
muy bien ahora podríamos pasar a la
siguiente a la siguiente pregunta dice
cuál es el número máximo posible de
mosquitos muy bien y esta respuesta la
podemos resolver fácilmente observando
lo siguiente esta función que nos
describe el número de millones de
mosquitos es una función cuadrática
verdad aquí podríamos ver de hecho lo
hacer rápidamente esto es menos erre por
r es menos ere cuadrada y menos r por
menos 4 es más 4 r entonces si te das
cuenta
esto es una función cuadrática entonces
se ve más o menos como una parábola de
hecho se ve exactamente una parábola
verdad puede tener la siguiente forma
puede tener la forma digamos puede ser
así
en el caso en este caso tendrá un valor
máximo o puede verse de esta forma en
cuyo caso tendrá un valor mínimo si no
se está preguntando cuál es el número
máximo posible de mosquitos esperaríamos
que tenga la forma de la izquierda y eso
está muy bien justamente porque tenemos
este signo menos digamos acompañando a
la erre verdad y entonces lo que voy a
hacer en este momento es reescribir esta
función digamos en la forma de vértice
para las parábolas y por supuesto si a
lo mejor esto no tiene mucho sentido
para ti pues te invito a que vean los
vídeos que tenemos aquí en cana que a
demi de cómo pasar a la forma de vértice
para las parábolas muy bien si tú
recuerdas o si ya has visto el vídeo
podrás recordar que la forma de vértice
es de la forma m igual a una constante
por un binomio al cuadrado r - b al
cuadrado
otra constante muy bien esta es la forma
de vértice verdad y que es bastante útil
para ver dónde se encuentran el mínimo y
el máximo ok entonces ahora lo que vamos
a hacer es completar el trinomio
cuadrado perfecto y nuevamente si a lo
mejor sientes que te estoy hablando en
un idioma muy extraño pues te invito a
que veas el vídeo de cómo completar
trinomios y bueno de paso ver el vídeo
de la forma de vértice para las
parábolas muy bien entonces vamos a
completar el trinomio ok entonces
tenemos nuestra expresión para m m es
igual la voy a dejar este signo menos
fuera y tenemos r por r que es re
cuadrada y ere x menos 4 que es menos 4
r muy bien entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es sumar alguna constante ok vamos a
sumar alguna constante para que esto se
quede como un trinomio cuadrado perfecto
ahora bien esa constante si viste los
vídeos es tomamos este coeficiente que
es menos 4 lo dividimos entre 2
- 2 y lo elevamos al cuadrado al
elevarlo al cuadrado nos da 4 y es lo
que hay que sumar para obtener el
trinomio cuadrado perfecto y por
supuesto tú dirás oye pero si sumas te 4
pues eso ya te cambia la igualdad verdad
o no no puedes estar agregando con
números y ya tenemos que quitar lo que
hemos agregado entonces a lo mejor tú
estarías no sé tentado a decir bueno si
agregamos 4 pues hay que restar 4 pero
hay que tener mucho cuidado este 4 lo
agregamos dentro de este paréntesis y el
paréntesis está x menos así que en
realidad de este lado tenemos un -4
verdad si queremos que la igualdad se
conserven nosotros no podemos restar 4
sino sumar 4 verdad para que no haya
afectado en nada la expresión entonces
en realidad así nos queda muy bien ya
hemos sumado 4
y restado 4 y esta expresión que tenemos
del lado y digamos en este paréntesis no
es otra cosa más
r - 2 al cuadrado muy bien ahora tenemos
aquí el signo menos y además estamos
sumando 4 muy bien así que ya tenemos la
función digamos expresado en su forma de
vértice ahora lo que nos falta es hacer
un análisis y el análisis es muy
sencillo veamos esta parte que tenemos
aquí con el signo menos y el paréntesis
y elevado al cuadrado todo esto
justamente siempre va a ser menor o
igual que 0 verdad cualquier cosa
elevada al cuadrado es mayor o igual que
0 pero x menos es menor o igual que 0 y
después estamos sumando 4 que es una
constante
entonces si nos ponemos a pensar cuándo
va a ser el valor máximo pues quiere
decir cuando esto sea cero verdad es
decir que le estamos quitando lo menos
posible y cuando le quitamos lo menos
posible es cuando vale cero
muy bien entonces nos preguntamos cuándo
vale estos 0 pues es justamente cuando
menos r - 2 al cuadrado es 0 verdad y
eso pasa cuando ere menos dos vale cero
y r menos dos vale cero si r es igual a
dos muy bien ahora podemos resolver ya
la la segunda pregunta cuál es el número
máximo posible de mosquitos el número
máximo posible de mosquitos es cuando
esta cuestión vale cero y eso nos dice
que m es igual a 4 entonces el valor
máximo posible de mosquitos es 4
millones 4 millones muy bien a partir de
cuántos centímetros de lluvia ocurrirá
el máximo número de mosquitos bueno eso
es justamente lo que acabamos de
encontrar es cuando r es igual a 2 es
decir la respuesta es 2 centímetros de
lluvia muy bien entonces ahí en cuando
tenemos dos centímetros de lluvia
alcanza su máximo después puede ser que
el aaiún
estoy llevando a los mosquitos a lo
mejor no sé o se están ahogando verdad y
se ahogan hasta cuando tenemos 4
centímetros cuando tenemos 4 centímetros
ya no hay mosquitos y después quizás el
modelo ya no tiene sentido porque
tendríamos una cantidad negativa de
millones de mosquitos y eso no tiene
nada de sentido así que realmente el
análisis importante es cuando el número
de o más bien cuando cuando los
centímetros de lluvia se encuentran
entre 0 y 4 muy bien entonces aquí con
esto terminamos el ejercicio espero que
te haya parecido interesante